so I know for sure there's at least one
thing I have in common with dentist I
absolutely hate the holiday of Halloween
now this hatred stems not from a dislike
of cavities
nor was it a lifetime in the making
rather does hatred stems from a
particular incident that happened nine
years ago nine years ago I was even
younger I was 20 years old and I was an
intern in the White House the other
white house and my job was to work with
mayors and councils nationwide November
1st 2010 began just like any other day I
turned on the computer went on Google
and prepared to write my news clips I
was met with a call from my mother which
isn't an album the war on my mom likes a
text called email Facebook Instagram all
day so I I answered the phone expected
to hear maybe some church gossip or
maybe something from WorldStarHipHop she
had discovered but but but when I
answered the phone I was met with a tone
that was unlike anything I've ever heard
from my mother my mother's loud but she
spoke and a hush still muffled tone that
conveyed a sense of sadness and as she
whispered she said Michael your cousin
Darnell was murdered last night on
Halloween at a house party in Stockton
and like far too many people in this
country particularly from communities
like mine particularly that look like me
I spent the better part of a year
dealing with anger rage nihilism another
choice to make the choice was one
between action and apathy that the
choice was what could I do to put
purpose to this pain I spent a year
dealing with feelings of survivor's
guilt what was the point of me being at
Stanford what was the point of me being
at the White House if I was powerless to
help my own family and my own family was
dying
quite literally I then begin to feel a
little selfish and say well what's the
point of even trying to make the world a
better place
maybe that's just the way it is maybe
I'll be smart to take advantage of all
the opportunities given to me and make
as much money as possible so I'm
comfortable and my media family is
comfortable but finally towards the end
of that year I realized I went to do
something so I made the crazy decision
as a senior in college to run for City
Council on that that decision was
unlikely for a couple reasons and not
just my age you see my family is far
from a political dynasty more men in my
family had been incarcerated than in
college in fact as I speak today my
father is still incarcerated
my mother she had me as a teenager and
government wasn't something we have warm
feelings from you see it was the
government that redline the
neighborhood's I grew up in full of
liquor stores and no grocery stores they
were lack of opportunity and
concentrated poverty it was the
government and politicians that made
choices like the war on drugs and three
strikes I've incarcerated far too many
people in our country it was the
government and political actors that
made the decisions that created a school
funding formulas that made so the school
I went to receive less prep ooh yes for
people spending the schools and more
affluent areas so there was nothing
about that background that made it
likely for me to choose to be involved
in being a government actor and at the
same time that Stockton was a very
unlikely place somethings my hometown
the city of 320,000 people but
historically it's been a place people
run from rather than come back to it's a
city that's incredibly diverse 35% of
Latino 35% white 20% Asian 10% African
American the oldest Sikh temple in North
America but at the time I ran for office
you were also the largest city in the
country at that time to declare
bankruptcy at the time I decided to run
for office we also have more murders per
capita than Chicago at the time I
decided to run for office with a 23%
poverty rate a 17% college attainment
rate and the host of challenge is an
issue beyond the scope of any 21 year
old so where after I won my election I
did like usually do when I feel
overwhelmed I realized the problems of
Stockton or far bigger than me and I
might need a little divine
intervention so as I prepared for my
first council meeting I went back to
some wisdom my grandmother taught me a
parable I think we all know that really
constitutes the governing frame were
using to reinvent Stockton today
remember in Sunday school my grandmother
told me that one time a guy asked Jesus
who was my neighbor who was my fellow
citizen Who am I responsible for and
instead of a short answer jesus replied
with a parable he said there was a man
on the journey walking down a Jericho
Road as he was walking down the road he
was beat up he was left on the side of
the road stripped of all his clothes
everything stolen from him and left to
die and then a priest came by saw the
man on the side of the road maybe sit a
silent prayer hopes and prayers our
prayers we gets better maybe saw the men
on the side of the road and surmise that
it was ordained by God for this
particular man this particular group
should be on the side that wrote and
there's nothing I could do to change it
and then after the priest walked by
maybe a politician walked by that 28
year old politicians for example saw the
man on the side of the road and saw how
beat up the man was saw that the man was
a victim of violence or fleeing violence
and the politician decide you know what
instead of welcoming this man in let's
build a wall maybe the policy just said
biggest man chose to be on the side of
the road that if he just pulled himself
up by his bootstraps
despite his boots being stolen and got
himself back on the horse he could be
successful there's nothing I could do
and then finally my grandmother said a
Good Samaritan came by saw the man on
the side of the road and looked and saw
not centuries of hatred between Judah
Samaritans
saw saw looked and saw not his fears
reflected my economic anxiety not what's
gonna happen to me because things are
changing but looked and saw reflection
of himself he saw his neighbor he saw
his common humanity and he and just see
it he did something about it my
grandmother said he got down on one knee
he made sure the man was okay and I
heard even gave him a room at that nice
Fairmont I think it's the Pan Pacific
one
and and and as I prepared to govern I
realized that given the diversity of
Stockton that the first step to making
change will be to again answer the same
question who is our neighbor and
realizing that our destiny as a city was
tied up in everyone particularly those
who are left on the side of the road but
then I realized that charity is
injustice that acts of empathy is
injustice by being a good neighbor is
necessary but not sufficient and that
was more that had to be done so looking
at the story I realized that the road
Jirka Road has a nickname it's known as
the bloody pass there's sin of red
because the road is structured for
violence
this Jerrica road is narrow it's
conducive for ambushing meeting a man on
the side of the road wasn't that normal
was it strange and in fact it was
something that was structured to happen
it was supposed to happen
and Jonathan Ghul turning a piece there
is talks about structural violence in
our society
he said structural violence is the
avoidable impairment of basic human
needs Paul Farmer dr. Paul Farmer talks
about structural violence and talks
about house away our institutions our
policies our culture creates outcomes
that advantage some people and
disadvantage others and and then I
realized much like the road and in
Jericho that in many ways stopped in our
society has been structured for the
outcomes we complain about that we
should not be surprised when we see that
kids and poverty don't do well in school
that we should not be surprised to see
wealth gaps and by race ethnicity we
should not be surprised to see income
pay disparities between genders because
that's what our society historically has
been structured to do it's working
accordingly so
so taking this wisdom I rolled up my
sleeves and began to work and there's
three quick stories I want to share that
point to not that we figured everything
out not that we have arrived but we're
trending in the right direction
the first story about the neighbor when
I was a city council member I was
working with one of the most
conservative members in our community on
opening a health clinic foreign
documented people in the south part of
the city and I loved it
and as we open the clinic we were ha we
had the resolution to sign he presented
me a gift it was an O'Reilly Factor
lifetime membership pin mind you I
didn't ask what he did to get such a
gift the blood elves I had no idea where
how he got it but I looked at him and I
said well how are we working together to
open a health clinic to provide free
health care for undocumented people and
you're an O'Reilly Factor member he
looked at me and said councilman Tubbs
that's this is for my neighbors and he's
a great example of what it means to be a
good neighbor at least in that instance
um the robbers so after four years on
City Council I decided to run for mayor
realizing that being a part-time
councilman wasn't enough to enact the
structural changes we need to see men
stop and it became it I came to that
conclusion by looking at the data so my
old council district where I grew up is
ten minutes away from a more affluent
district and ten minutes away in the
same city the difference between zip
code 95 - oh five and ninety five to one
to a nine and life expectancy is ten
years ten minutes away four point five
miles 10 years life expectancy
difference and not because of the
choices people are making because no one
chose to live in an unsafe community
where they can't exercise no one chose
to put more liquor stores and grocery
stores in their community no one chose
these things but but this reality I
realized as a councilman to enact a
structural change I want to see word
between the same zip codes there's a 30%
difference in the rate and unemployment
there's a $75,000 a year difference in
income that being
councilman was not going to cut it so
that's when I decided to run for mayor
and as mayor we've been focused on the
robbers and the road um so in Stockton
as I mentioned we historically have had
problems with violent crime in fact
that's why I decided to run for office
in the first place and my first job as
mayor would be helping our community to
see ourselves our neighbors not just the
people victimized by violence but also
by the perpetrators we realized that
that those who in that pain in our
society of those who are committing the
homicides and contributing a gun
violence are oftentimes victims
themselves they have high rates of
trauma they have been shot at they know
people who have been shot and as I
excuse their behavior but it helps
explaining us as a community we have to
see these folks as us too
but they too are our neighbors so for
the past three years so for the past
three years we've been working on two
strategies ceasefire and advance peace
where we give these guys as much
attention as a much loved from social
services from opportunities from tattoo
removals in some cases even cash as I
get from law enforcement and last year
we saw a 40% reduction in homicides and
a 30% reduction in violent crime and now
the road I mentioned that my community
has a 23% poverty rate someone who comes
from poverty it's a personal issue for
me so I decided that we wouldn't just do
a program or we wouldn't just do
something to go on the edges but we were
called into question the very structure
that produces poverty in the first place
so starting in February we launched a
basic income demonstration where for the
next 18 months as a pilot 130 families
randomly selected who live in zip codes
at or below the median income of the
city are giving us $500 a month and
we're doing this for a couple of reason
we're doing it because we realized that
something is structurally wrong in
America when one and two Americans can't
afford one Florida dollar emergency
we're doing it because we realize that
something is structurally wrong when the
wages have only increased six percent
between 1979 and 2013 we're doing it
because we realize something is
structurally wrong when people are
working too
three jobs doing all the jobs no one in
here what's to do and can't pay for
necessities like rent like lights like
health care like like child care so I
would say Stockton again we have real
issues I have constituent emails on my
phone now about the homelessness issue
about from the violent crime we're still
experiencing but I would say I think as
a society we would be wise to go back to
those old Bible stories we were talking
up and understand that number one we
have to begin to see each other as
neighbors that when we see someone
different from us they should not
reflect our fears our anxieties our
insecurities the prejudices we've been
taught or by ACS but we should see
ourselves we should see our common
humanity cuz I think once we do that we
can do the more important work of
restructuring the road because again I
understand some listening are saying
well
Meritage they're talking about
structural violence in structural this
but you're on the stage that the
structures can't be too bad if you could
come up from poverty have a father in
jail go to Stanford working at white
house may come there and I will respond
by saying the term for that is
exceptionalism meaning that we recognize
it's exceptional for people to escape
the structures meeting by our very
language we understand that the things
we see in our world are by design I
think the task for us as testers and as
good people just people and world people
as really do the hard work necessary of
not just joining hands as neighbors but
using our hands to restructure a row the
road that in this country has been
reading in themes like white supremacy a
road like in this country has been
rooted in things like massage a road
that's not working for far too many
people and I think today tomorrow and
2020 we have a chance to change that so
as I prepare to close I started with a
story from nine years ago and I in all
in with one so after my cousin was
murdered I was lucky enough she's going
to Freedom Rides with some of their
original Freedom Riders and they taught
me a lot about restructuring the road
and one guy in particular Bob Segall to
ask me a question now I'm going to leave
with us today
he were going through Anniston Alabama
and he said Michael I said yes sir he
said I was arrested on August 4th 1961
now why is that day important and I said
well you were arrested if you want to
arrest it would be on this bus if one of
this bus who's gonna have the rights we
enjoy
and he rolled his eyes and he said no
son he said on that day Barack Obama was
born and then he said he had no idea
that the choice he made to restructure
the road would pave the way so a child
born of a second-class citizen who
wouldn't be able to even get a cup of
water on the counter
will have the chance fifty years later
to be president then he looked at me and
he said what are you prepared to do
today so that 50 years from now a child
born has a chance to be present and I
think Ted that's the question before us
today we know things are jacked up I
think what we've seen recently isn't
abnormally but a reflection of a system
that has been structured to produce such
crazy outcomes but I think it's also an
opportunity because these structures we
inherit on acts of God but acts admit
and women their policy choices they buy
politicians like me and and approved by
voters like you and we have the chance
and they are some opportunity to do
something about it so my question is
what are we prepared to do today so that
a child born today 50 years from now
isn't born in a society rooted in white
supremacy isn't born into a society
riddled with misogyny isn't born into a
society riddled with homophobia and
transphobia and anti-semitism and
Islamophobia and ableism and all the
fobian isms what are we prepared to do
today so that 50 years from now we have
a road in our society that is structured
to to to reflect what we hold to be
self-evident that all men that all women
that even all trans people are created
equal and are endowed with their creator
with certain inalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness thank you
[Applause]